[Music]
[Applause]
I I just woke up from my
dreams well you and I had to say
goodbye and I don't know what it all
means but since I survived I
realized where ever you go that's where
I'll
follow nobody's promise
tomorrow so I'm going love you every
night like it's the last night like it's
the last night if the world was ending I
want to be next to
you if the party was over and all time
on Earth was through
o I want to hold you just for a
while and
down with the
SM there the world was ending God want
to be next to
[Music]
you
oh
L lost in and the words that we
scream I don't even want to do this
anymore cuz you already know what you
mean to me and I love they I want we're
fighting
for wherever you go that's where I'll
follow nobody's promised
tomorrow so I'm going love you every
night like it's the last night
like it's the last night if the world
was ending I want to be next to
you if the party was over and I time of
life was
through I going to hold you just for a
around
and with the smile
if the world was ending I'd want to be
next to
you right next to
you to
you right next to you
[Applause]
if the world was standing I'd want to be
next to
true if the party was over and that time
on Earth was
true I want hold you just for a
while and
die with the
smile and the world was ending I want to
be next to
you if the world was ending I want to be
next to you
[Applause]
[Music]
want to be next
to Hey There friends so I hope you
enjoyed that flow session um I will
admit I was not a huge fan of that song
when I first heard it but uh seeing so
many amazingly talented dancers out on
Instagram and Tik Tok really turned my
opinion around on it and now I love it
so yeah uh I hope you enjoy that jam
from Lady Gaga and Bruno Mars as much as
I do and if you enjoyed the visuals
guess what you can get a discount on a
set of the poy that I was using in this
video These are orb poy pros from Ultra
poy if you use the promo code Drex
factor with a zero in stud of an O over
at checkout at ultra.com you can get 10%
off your own pair once again that is
Drex factor with a zero instead of an o
thank you so much to ultra poy for
sponsoring this video and giving me an
excuse to go out and get my flow on also
big thanks go out to the Friends of the
channel uh big thanks go to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys pyro ter
light toys and Ultra poy for helping to
make the videos on this channel possible
you can learn more about all these
amazing companies and the work that
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non-business
friend of the channel That is Becca
Becken thank you so very much for
supporting my mission my channel and my
work and finally this video and all the
videos on this channel would not be
possible without my amazing supporters
on patreon in particular I want to give
a shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now thank you so
much you all rock and if you are Keen to
watch me get some more flow on I will go
ahead and include a link to a playlist
of videos of me doing just that uh down
in the description as well as up on
screen thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow yourselves
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care peace